I did what are we doing today today's
gonna be a very interesting day we're
gonna have a guest come over from
Sacramento California
not one six this is dude named Rob so
number one god man papa
number one buffet Slayer you seen
everything with a Food Network your man
man vs. food no this is dude vs. buffet
now I've been trapped through a Vince a
while ago I think it was because we
thought we were trying to go sketch
together that actually came out terrible
but my man Davis stole man we play
tetherball right and then like this dude
just came up and he's just like oh man
this dude's going the wrong circle right
msg all day long interesting man the
last time rod was here we were in Cape
Town cuz that's where I used to live it
was that kid cosplay and then I remember
hey man I would support you all the way
a hundred percent i watch all your
videos on my phone later yeah I looked
at his head and this fool had a [ __ ]
black-and-white flip phones are you
gonna watch my videos on your [ __ ]
non-colored [ __ ] LCD flip
they didn't fit in the suitcase wrong
outfit I got the monk straps though with
the matching belt so I think should
explain to people how you develop that
beat boy David Dirty Sanchez appropriate
well just say like you alright it's a
kegger where I was in high school so it
was inappropriate altogether and of
course I was being inappropriate with a
lot of females there and some of them
more or less we're just telling me what
a marriage my husband's right there it's
for you is stop more or less preferences
like man this guy's doesn't carry
straight dirty dude you know what we're
calling the dirty sanchez
and of course like I never knew what
that was for the longest time so you
didn't know what dirty sanchez was but
you walked about telling everybody your
name was dirty Sanjay no I get
introduced that way portraits and
canvases I feel like shirts and maybe
like and go getting like swag that says
that like I says dirty sanchez yeah yeah
I'm gonna subtract trapped and [ __ ] did
you not wear it today
you need to explain to me exactly what
was going on that [ __ ] Facebook
picture where you addressed as the exact
same thing you were eating that was like
a moment of clarity if anything else I'm
like holy crap viewed this thing looks
exactly what I'm wearing so I'll say all
right let's do this I don't know how you
ever got a pumpkin roll suit I need to
understand if this is the costume or you
hook up insid this one [ __ ] told me you
got a brand new Honda CRV oh it's not
even like a brand-new one it's like a
courtesan you know make CRV that yeah I
got like an old mechanic friend he was
just all about like you do we could fix
this man he's like he tells me
everything and I understand nothing why
did you want to get like a more modern
car that would last you more than like
three years
I should how many miles is your share of
you 270 King what the [ __ ] why would you
buy that car
Integra GSR and that was like kind of
like the worst idea ever I never got
profiled in a car ever
cops and pull me over just a sea of like
if I stole my own car like littering
they're like hey can you pop them but
this isn't Street League like what is
it's like I don't know what you're
talking about
so you have this card you don't even
know what's under the mat no I'm a
friend told me to buy this one too
why do you keep going back to this
friend this here keeps on going down and
down and down it's a good friend and
always how is he a good friend he
[ __ ] dumped you to my two crappy cars
well he helps me when they go to ground
of course he helps you back because he's
making a profit of us sitting in this
shitty-ass cars you're the only friend
that would buy it yeah listen your dude
I got the shitty ass car that's gonna
break down in two years it's gonna be
great for you
you like you know what sounds good dude
this is hella Genki when you like get a
girl to like go in your car and then you
gotta like like the door locks on work
on top of that is just like like
everything's just kind of like oh wait
let me just like adjust this and that
and it's just like just like a it's okay
I'm just gonna take a new word yeah so
I've been cocked like but buy my own car
I'm gonna describe how odd this man is
even he sweats weird do you understand
that when you're at a club like usually
you sweat through specific [ __ ] for a
second
this was sweated through his arms his
neckline and his nipples look at this it
looks like a Japanese like anime cartoon
ghosts right here you gotta tell me what
it's like
odd so if there's a tank top under here
that bees underneath that tank top he
cut out nipple hole